dans les pubs vous savez r&d au crédit
mutuel ils sont en train d'installer des
outils d'intelligence artificielle pour
les conseiller au crédit mutuel
la technologie est au service des
conseillers dans la vie vous avez hervé
au crédit mutuel sont en train
d'installer des outils d'intelligence
artificielle pour les conseiller mais
pourquoi tu parles de banque avec mon
père la chaire et je sais pas je me suis
dit que ça pouvait être intéressant
non non non je m'en bats les couilles et
oui tu peux pas parler de jeu pas de
météo comme n'importe qui je n'ai
vraiment rien à [ __ ] ce matin au
marché pérenne à une surprise pour son
premier c'est la nouvelle crème légère
l'exquise de brider lice une vraie
révolution
un goût si vrai enfin d'une crème légère
longue conservation avec ce matin au
marché le ver était une surprise pour
son crime roux qui souffre est là c'est
la vérité c'est quoi ces l'abri des
lices
je veux pas causer de l'abri des
liseuses ou vendent la crème sucrée
mieux bien lire qu'il est vôtre vous
êtes sérieuse là vous voulez ce montant
pour dire que votre com de merde est
meilleure que la mienne elle est
vraiment meilleure et plus onctueuse et
cela mais voulait mettre au chômage
devient votre boulot pour vous mettre au
chômage voit le soleil vous guide dans
les pubs mais installe toi j'ai eu 16
ans super bon ce qui te souviennes su
mêler derrière oui bien sûr non parce
que les gens veulent retrouver l'essai
sans gluten en moyenne vous allez passer
trente neuf mille quatre cent douze
heures dans votre cuisine
la vie j'imagine que ça je mange pas non
plus non désolé par contre je viens
viens d'où sa g l et déminéralisée tu te
casses tu te barres de chez moi j'ai pu
voir oui pardon barreau toi désolé dans
les pub tue ou bien de changer de banque
par week-end à rome
tu t'attends à la voiture fortuneo c'est
pour ça que j'aime ma banque dans la vie
que tu vas où j'aime changer de banque
on part en week end à rome mais on est
toujours découvert oui on comprend d'une
part une couche et oui on me demande
souvent si la première semaine gratuite
est vraiment gratuite oui c'est gratuit
pour que vous testiez pendant une
semaine c'est gratuit parce qu'on sait
que ça marche et que ça vous plaira
un pays c'est gratuit parce qu'on sait
vous n'avez pas demandé le remboursement
c'est super chiant pour envoyer les
produits vous imaginez faire des petites
boîtes comme ça est la poste les
renvoyer non cerveau près en plus c'est
gratuit
parce que c'est rentable pour nous
technologie ce qu'il fit la matière
innovante dans la vie ils sont
tranquilles 1 comporte quoi ah bah si
ils veulent mettre une capote de quoi je
veux voir
[Musique]
justin
mais pourquoi tu as jeté l'union qui par
terre et m'a pas pourquoi bas il devait
être dans la poêle à la base oui bah là
ils sont par terre oui bah je sais bien
je les ai jeté trop c'est pour ça mais
pourquoi tu es jette pourquoi tu fais
pas glisser dans la peau et c'est bon
j'ai compris je sais j'ai fait comme
dans la pub c'est pour ça je vous mets
sous lé là on commet des pizzas ce soit
dans les pubs où mon père il est
tellement fort qu'il est ses poulets qui
sauvent antibio baby voix l'appétit mais
mon poulet est mort c'était mon ami mon
rejeton poulet ta faute
allez pas s'attacher à lui mort je
[Musique]
souffert quand tu es tu et oui après une
nuit agitée dans la gorge d'alice une
vague d'irritation au sud accompagne une
pluie de picotements et oui après une
nuit agitée dans la gorge d'alice une
vague d'irritation attend elle a fait
quoi hier lice en fait ouais donc ils
étaient combien de 10 dans les pubs et
pas versailles ici artus et versailles
non puisque nous sommes à grenoble
satellitaire c'est pas personne on va où
trouve à versailles non dans les pubs
demeurant plein de gens mais pas la
preuve mamie comment je peux me faire
pardonner
lui tel un la journée du bon côté aux
jeux ne reflue j'aime pas la preuve
mamie comment je peux me faire pardonner
je lègue toute ma fortune à mes
petits-enfants et oublie pas la villa en
corse way you lie pas dans les pubs mais
évidemment prête à tout pour essayer la
peugeot 208 dans la vie faut absolument
que j'aille lui parler tu peux prêter sa
voiture banon mais il en train de me
quitter faut que je me rattrape je vais
t'accompagner c'est une juste besoin de
ta voiture pas de toi dedans mes jambes
comme en fait tu peux prendre un taxi
passe complètement convaincu et avec
aiguille on sait comment garder
[Musique]
jardin bad
en fait on a vu des kidnappings oui je
m'en fout en fait c'est une propriété
privée vous avez rien à faire laver vos
voisins oui on veut des membres hall
il ya une épicerie à côté vous aller en
acheter c'est tout j'appelle apprécié
mon erreur ni roi je lui dis que ça
marcherait et puis arrêtez cette
démarche c'est ridicule at arrête arrête
c'est gino dans les pumas interruption
spécial accrochage en ville benoit vous
devez être sous le choc n'ont fait rien
quand même avec tout ce qui vous attend
les expertises des réparations vous
allez perdre un temps précieux faut du
tout avec mes mains mobilité premium
c'est simple et rapide
envoyez la pub aura des interruptions
spécial accrochage en ville benoit à
elle devait être sous le choc
dieu quoi je suis un jack là avec tout
ce qui vous attend les expertises les
réparations vous allez perdre un temps
précieux quoi vont filmer moi il ya
d'autres choses à filmer barrez-vous là
moi j'ai embouti ma voiture laisse moi
tranquille on me dit que eric zemmour
voudrais intervenir sur le sujet je m'en
branle eux sont d'avis elle lui paraît
vous allez puis d'autres choses béguin
pour lui la pub
[Musique]